- Yle Areena.
[Musiikkia]
- Reikko täällä Hännsingissä, terve. Päättelin osa aikaa sitten näitä tierrätysprosentteja. Saksassa se oli jotain kahdeksankymmentä, mutta meillä -
se oli jotain neljäkymmentäviisi paikkeilla. Tätä kierrätystä voisi lisätä sillä lailla, että kun tulee vaali, niin nämä vaalimainokset kerätään yhteen ja mökkiläiset, suomalaiset, kun on mökkikansa, niin veisivät sinne mökille ne ja huussin naulaan. Ja sitten kun isäntä tai emäntä käy siellä mäkin huusissa, niin sitten kattelee, että jaa, kenenkäs vaalilupa on.
Täällä tässä nyt sitten pyyhitään. Siinä tuli semmoinen oikeakunnan kierrätys. Kiitos, hei. - Tuota neuvoa ei varmaankaan pidä ottaa ihan kirjaimellisesti. Se saattoi enemmänkin olla turhautumisen alleviivaamista. Sen jos ottaa kirjaimellisesti, niin saattaa tulla ihmiselle haavoja. Eikö tuollainen julistepaperi ole kumminkin suhteellisen kovaa? Mutta mielipide selväksi sellaista se on tässä ohjelmassa. Se on -
Kansan Radio ja Lasse Olkinuora tässä tervehdyissä. Dronia, Vappu Marssia, dieselveroa muun muassa niitä aiheita kommentoidaan tämänkertaisessa jaksossa, jossa myös vähän hätäillään, että ei kai vaan tulevaisuudessa meiltä tulla kieltämään hernerokkaa. Edeltävältä viikolta puolestaan jää nyt mietityttämään vähän euroviisut ja sitä edeltävältä puolestaan Hela torstai. Eli nyt seuraavaksi pyhäpäivän kautta laulukilpailuun. - Sinikka täällä on.
Keravalta päivää, kun kuuntelin radiosta näitä uutisia, kun puhuttiin taas tästä Helatorstain vietosta, että joko sitä taas yritetään siirtää johonkin muuhun paikkaan, kun se on jo kerran Hellalauantai, jota minä ihmettelin. Ja sitten yksi, kaksi, taas joku keksi, että ei kun siirretään se takaisin siihen missä sen paikka on eli Helatorstain.
Että kukas nyt on taas tämmöiseen? Onko se taas nämä työmarkkinalaitokset, jotka nyt haluankin sitä taas siirtää johonkin lauantaille? Että tämmösiä minä ihmettelen, että jospa joku järkevä selittäisi, että mitä tämä tämmöinen oikein tarkoittaa, ettei jaksata pysyä siinä oikeassa paikassa, mihin se kuuluu. Hei vaan.
Oikein hyvin. Näin pitikin käydä, kun ne etukäteen vauhkas ja vauhkas pari kuukautta ainakin jo, että kyllä Suomi voittaa. Se on ennakkosuosikki. Ja tässä viime päivinäkin jo jankkasivat, että missäs kummassa paikassa pidetään? Kummassa kaupungissa Tampereella vai Helsingissä? Mutta ei voittaneetkaan. Ai piru kun kävi hyvin. Näin pitikin käydä. Älä nuolaisi ennen kuin tipahtaa, että se on aina isompi pettymys mitä enemmän ollaan ottamassa.
Palkintoa etukäteen, kun ei ole vielä lauluja lauettukaan. Tää meni ihan oikein. Ja sitä paitsi siellä ei ollut kunnon musiikkia yhtään. Sellainen voittaa yleensä ei ole persepaljana kaikkein eniten. Paljon vaan kun on reittä näkyviin ja haaraa sieltä ja pitkä vartista saapasta jalkaan. Semmoinen on tyyli nykyään, että sinne voitto rapsahtaa, koska hänne perkeleen esiintyy ihan alasti. Paljon pajasta pintaa esille seuraavalla kerrallaani. Voitto kotiin että napsaa.
Hei Jumala loi Peten. Kansanradio. No tässä Eero terve. Terve Eero. Tosiaan tämmöinen hommeli tuli mieleen tuosta kun eräs henkilö ilmoitti että televisio ei näy. Niin tuota minulla on semmoinen mielipide tähän asiaan että ei sen tarvikkaan näkyvä telkkarista ei tule kerta kaikkiaan mitään hyvää. Ei tule mitään hyvää. Ei yhtään mitään. Siis Ylen kanavat tuoltaan hyvät.
Ainoat harvinaiset. Harvinaiset josta nyt sentään tulee uutiset mutta ei niitäkään tarvitse katsoa kun kaikki uutisetkin on ihan sanonka mistä kun nykyään maailmassa tapahtuu niin paljon pahoja asioita niin mitäpä niitä nyt suhtaan sitten kahtelemaan. Kyllä silmille tulee ne droonit ilmaan että niitä kattoo telkkarista. Niin tietysti onhan sitä hyvä olla vähän tietoinen että mitä ympärillä tapahtuu mutta mutta mutta. No enpä tiedä. Enpä tiedä. Kyllä se kyllä se tulee vaikkei kahtoskaa. No se on totta kyllä mutta.
Et siis keksi mitään katsottavaa televisiosta? - No Euroviisuun jakahdettiin, mutta nekin katottiin Areenasta eikä no televisiotahan se sekki on tietysti, mutta tuota enpä nyt oikeastaan keksi mitään hyvää. Varsinkaan kaupallisilta kanavilta ei siellä ole oikeasti mitään kattomista.
Eli tämä perinteinen ikään kuin aikataulu televisio niin se jää historiaan ja suoratoista palveluja sitten katsotte? - No en pakko kyllä niitäkään. Ei niitäkään? - Ei ei. Ei siis tuota se mitä nyt haluaa katsoa niin se löytyy sieltä Areenasta ja no se nyt on suoratoista palvelun tietysti sekin mutta enimmäkseen sielläkin käytän kyllä näitä audiopalveluita. - Joo joo okei mutta välillä sitten totta kai perusvelvollisuuden täytet ja katsot vähän kummelia.
No kyllä lähtee. - Jos ei suomalainen välillä kummelia katso niin ihme on. - No se on jo sairautta jos ei kummelia pystyttämään mutta tuota mutta joo ei minulla oikeastaan tämän kummempaa olla. - Hyvä juttu kun soitit. - Joo. - Minä toivoton päivän jatkossa. - Kiitoksia hauskasta ohjelmasta. - Kiitos paljon kiitos kun olet seurassa. - Olen. - Jes. - Juu moi. - Televisiosta puheen ollen iso äiti Tampereelta on laittanut meille sähköpostia siitä kuinka ruokajonot kattavat.
punalappuisia ostetaan, mutta MasterChef -ohjelmassa ruokavarastosta haetaan lihakimpaleita, kokonaisia kaloja, vihanneksia, hedelmiä ja juureksia. Ja kuitenkin niistä käytetään vain osa valmistukseen ja valmiista ruoasta vain osa viedään tuomareille. Mihin laitetaan ne yli jääneet ruoka-ainekset, joita ei käytetä? Hukka ruokaako suoraan biojätteeseen? Olisi hyvä tuoda se julki. Samasta aiheesta tullut hiljattain toinenkin viesti.
Minä ajattelin, että tuotahan olisi ihan hyvä kysyä. Laitoin viestiä MasterChefin vastaavalle tuottajalle Jenni Nyrussille, joka vastasi, että pyrkimys on jo ihan ennakkovaiheesta lähtien ja koko tuotannon läpi kiinnittää huomiota hävikkiin jo siinä, että tilausmäärät ovat mietittyjä ja maltillisia ja kaikki mitä voidaan ottaa uudelleen käyttöön, otetaan tai jaetaan eteenpäin. Ja esimerkiksi avatut maitopurkit nehän päätyvät työryhmän kahvimaidoksiin.
ja niin edespäin. Meiltä lähtee joka viikko kuvausjakson aikana hävikkiä hyvän tekeväisyyteen ja kauden jälkeen lahjoitamme myös kaikki ylijääneet kuivatuotteet ja tuotteet jotka kestävät säilytystä Ukrainaan. Punnitsemme, seuraamme meidän biojäteen ja muuta jäteen määrää ja tuotannon päästöjä ja pyrimme pitämään ne mahdollisimman alhaisena. Näin siis vastasi ja kiitti vielä kysyjää kysymyksistä. No tässähän on ollut nyt jääkiekon MM-kisaaja
Euroviisuja ja vaikka mitä, mutta kyllä ne drooni taitaa olla ihan puhutuin uutisaihe. Sitä on luvassa seuraavaksi ja vähän myös maan puolustusta.
keskustelun taso ja poliittisten päättäjien ymmärryksen taso asioista. Minä olen itse ihmetellyt sitä, että miten tämä kuvio voi mennä niin, että me annamme rahaa Ukrainalle, joka rakentaa niitä drooneja ja sen jälkeen lennättää ne räjähdysainelastossa meidän rajamme yli. Sen jälkeen me ruvamme miettimään, että nyt meidän täytyy ottaa lisää rahaa siihen, että me voimme suojautua niiltä meidän rahoillamme ostetuina.
Minun mielestäni tässä kuviolla on jotain ihmeellistä ja kyllähän nyt ensisijaisesti meidän poliittikojen ja puolustusvoimeen täytyy saada loppumaan otteensa oikeuden droonien lentäminen tästä meidän rajamme yli. Meidän omilla rahoilla maksetuiden droonien, mutta täytyy keskittää näihin luonnon omeempiin kuin drooneihin ja jatkaa tätä linnunpötteen rakentelua. Hyvä kevättä.
Hyvänä harjoitteluna kuinka toimitaan tällaisessa tilanteessa? Tämä on harjoitusohjelmaa kerta kaikkiaan. Jos jotakin huomaatte, että olisi vähän parannettavaa, niin itse kirjatkaa ylös tai tietokoneelle ja tämä on erittäin hyvää harjoitusta.
En tiedä kuinka tahtoja on nyt tästä eteenpäin, mutta tämä sataa Suomelle ja Suomen kansalle plussaks laariin. Kiitoksia. Arvoisa pääministeri, mistä saan vaaratiedotteen tähän omaan peruspuhelimeeni? Tämä ei ole älypuhelin. Kiitos.
Haluaisin osoittaa tämän viestinnin lähinnä Suomen päättäjille. Onko mitenkään yhteydessä mukinnut ajatus päässä, että Suomi, Ruotsi, Norja, Tanska, Islanti ja Färsare ja muut oltais yhteinen puolustusvoimain unioni erikseen? Olisi yhteinen puolustusvoima ja puolustusvoimien tarvikeosto hankinta yhdessä. Mielestäni tämä olisi erittäin toimiva konsepti ja toisaalta näin voitais myös ajatella se, että kun on yhteinen puolustusvoima, niin tarvitaan yhteinen puolustusvoima.
Yhteispohjoismainen tämmöinen kokoonpano olisi yhtenäinen rahaa. Ei tarvittaisi euroa. Se voisi olla vaikka kruun, pohjoismainen kruun. Olen siten mieltä, että kannattaa miettiä todella tarkkaan, koska niin arvaamaton tuuliviiri on tuolla rapakon takana tuo mr. Trump ja toinen vielä hurjempi viiri on tuossa itäpuolella rajaputte, niin kannattaa miettiä moneen kertaan yhtä ne ostot tehdään, ketä otetaan rege ja ketä ei.
Selvä, ei kun kesä ei kölyttytä. Morjes!
Hannu terve. Terve Hannu. Olen emakoiden poika yli kahdeksankymppinen.
Isä opetti, että itänaapuri alkaa R:llä, niihin ei voi koskaan luottaa.
Ne valehtelee aina, niin kuin Putinikin puhupaska. Eihän länsi ohjoikenut heitä vastaan, niin kuin se väittää.
Joo. Ja ei muuta, kiitos. Kiitos paljon kun soitit. Mennyt viikko täällä Kansan radiossa herätti muun muassa seuraavanlaisia kommentteja.
Satu on laittanut meille WhatsAppitse viestin niille, jotka arvostelivat maamme presidenttiä siitä, että Mäntyniemi on saneerattu ja ennen kaikkea sitä, miten paljon siihen upposi rahoja, niin presidenttihän ei ratkaisua tehnyt. Hänellä ei ollut asian kanssa mitään tekemistä.
Rakennushan on jo niin vanha, että ilmeisesti sinne piti tehdä ihan normaaleita peruskorjauksia. Kaikkea hyvää kaikille, toivottaa viestin lähettänyt Satu.
Mummeli puolestaan on lähettänyt meille kortin kortin, jossa on kaunis kuva Kukka Seppeleestä. Tässä kortissa lukee, että siellä yhdessä lähetyksessä eräs rouva kommentoi, kuinka orpo ja purra ovat opposition haukkumisen kohteena jatkuvasti. Olen tämän rouvan kanssa samaa mieltä.
Voimia toivotan orpolle ja purralle. Terveisin siis Mummeli. - Kansanradio. - Miestä antaa rannikolta. Terve. - Terve. - Annanko tulla tälle sinne pienen viestin? - Anna tulla. - Tässä menneessä Kansanradiossa siis tänä päivänä sille vastaussille naiselle, joka kysyi kuinka paljon tämä nykyinen hallitus on ottanut velkaa.
Ja minun vastaus on, että edellinen temarihallitus Marinin johdolla otti velkaa neljäkymmentä miljardia euroa, jota nyt maksetaan. Siinä kaikki. Toivottavasti tämä menisi nimenomaan sille naiselle, että pitäisi muistelemaan vähän vanhojaakin juttuja ja jota nyt maksetaan nimenomaan maksetaan ja otetaan jopa köyhiltä sitä rahaa ja terveydenhuollossa.
Niin onko tää nyt ihan oikein? Ja sitten lässytetään siis ihan kaikkea muuta siitä, mutta tää on ollut niin kuin salainen. Koko tää neljäkymmentä miljardia. Siitä on puhuttu edes eduskunnan kyselytunnilla. Niin eikö se ole ihmeellistä?
- Mutta eikö hyvin useasti kun oppositio haastaa orpoa ja purraa, niin eikö ne hyvin useasti sano, että tässä maksetaan Marinin tietoja?
- Se onkin ihmeellistä kuulla, että ne eivät sano. - Mitenkäs minä muistelisi, että te ovat nimenomaan sanoneet monta kertaa näin, että edellinen hallitus on tehnyt sitä ja sitä, mutta ne eivät koskaan. Me olemme sen jälkeen kuunneet ja katsoneet nämä kyselytunnit. Yksikään oppositiosta eikä mistään muusta ole puhunut siitä sanaakaan. Elikkä siinä on joku ihme juttu, mutta nyt sinulla on pieni pähkinä purtavana.
ja tota toivotan sulle kumminkin kaikkia hyvää. - Hei minä toivotan oikein hyvät sunnuntait myös. - Kiitoksia. - Päivi jatkoi. - Kiitti hei. - No päiviä täällä yksi savolainen vaan täältä Savosta. Tuota oli pakko soittaa kun tota tässä on parikin ihmistä jo semmoista haasteellet että tämä jo tos saman tämän työterveyshuolto niin kuin lopettaa kokonaan ja sille mukaan tuota sitten kun saatais lääkäreitä lisää terveyskeskuksia ja jonot vähennäisi niin.
Niillä on tätä vaikka huono laskupääksi niin hän esiintyi ne potilatkin tuota lääkärien mukana että ei ne jonot ainakaan sille yhtään mihinkään tuota tämän hänelle ja tälle hallitukselle ei kannata tämmöisimmänne edittelemään tai sekin häviä meitä kohtaan että kannattaa pitteillä sitä asiaa tai ainakin suuttu. Tähän ei tässä tään kummempaa tavalla ole. Joo kiitos ei muuta. - Tapia Pohjois-Pohjanmaata soittelylle sävähtin sen verran korvaa tuota kansanradiossa tämä.
Valkosen marssin mies joka sanoi että haluaa olla maskipäässä niin mukaan niin rahansa marssivat ja sanotaan silti vaan hakataan naisia kesken marssi että eipä se kovin rahvistaa heiänkä toimintaa ollut. Ei mulla muuta. Moro.
- No tää on Kansanradion kuuntelija joka kuunteli nyt tässä 17.5. tätä Kansanradio. Nyt toivois Kansanradio siellä tulisi semmoisia iloisia aiheita eikä aina moitittasi.
Aina syytettäisi ja hallitus ja hallitus mutta me ei voida tälle nyt mitään ja sitten tää uudistus tähän eduskuntatalon tai Stubbin pariskuntaa nyt siitä että olisi välttänyt mutta kun se on kyllähän siis vuosia on ollut niin joskushan niitä uudistuksia ja kaikki uudistus maksaa että näin se vaan on mutta meidän täytyy vaan nyt kansalaisina tottua tähän että Suomi on menossa vähän niin kuin alas päin kaikessa ja näin mutta toivotaan että Kansanradiokin.
Nyt sai semmosta virikettä vähän että ei aina niitä huonoja uutisia löydettäisi nyt tässä elämässä vähän sitä iloa valoa ja kaikkea näin että kesä on tulossa ja muuta ja ei tässä itse kenelläkään ole niin hirveän ihanaa että on kaikenlaista ollut tässä elämässä mutta yritetään päivä kerrallaan mennä mutta ei mitään syvää kesän jatkoa tulevaisuudessa ja tätä kevään loppua. Nyt on kaunis päivä aurinko paistaa ja pidetään ilonen miele niin kiitos hei hei hei.
Toisaalta asian voi nähdä niinkin että harvoin sitä huomautellaan vioista ihan vaan huomauttelun iloksi. Kyllähän niitä epäkohtia nostetaan esiin että niihin tulisi muutoksia ja niihin kiinnitettäisiin huomiota. No menneessä se on hyvä piipahtaa niin kuin tuossa tehtiin ja sitten tiedä kannattaako ihmisen sinne jumittaa liian pitkäksi aikaa vastapainoksi. Kuunnellaan vähän tulevaisuuden näkymiä tai ehdotuksia sinne. Kansanvallan nimissä.
Olisi syytä saada veroilmoitukseen ruutukko jokaista ministeriötä varten ja näihin ruutukoihin ihmiset voisivat merkitä sen prosenttiluvun jonka osuuden he veroistansa haluaisivat kyseiselle ministeriölle.
Jos joku haluaa esimerkiksi tukea puolustusvoimia hän panee siihen ruutuun suuremman prosenttiluvun kun vastaavasti joku muu ministeriö johon hän ei halua tukeansa antaa panee tietysti pienemmän tai ei mitään.
Tämä olisi todellista kansanvaltaa. Siinä kansalaiset saisivat itse päättää mitä he haluavat tukea tässä eikä siihen tarvita tulkiksi politiikkoja jotka sanovat mihin kansalaisten maksamat verorahat käytetään.
Kun oli näistä koulusta että mitä koulussa voitais opettaa niin tuota minun mielestäni koulussa voitais opettaa jo ihan alaluokilta asti niin kuin pojillekin niin onko poikien pakko virkata neulaa ja tuollasta sehän on aivan älytöntä eikä silläkin voisi ajatella että opetettaisiin kodin omien vaatteiden huoltoa miten omellaan nappi miten korjataan joku vaate.
Miten silitetään miten pestään ihan sillä alkeisajatuksilla näitä voisi ajatella että ne olisi ihan kivoja että jätettäisiin joku semmoinen hömpäjuttu pois mutta siisteyttä ja omaa puhtautta ja omien vaatteitten huoltoa. Se on minusta tärkeätä. Kiitos hyvää jatkoa teille kaikille.
Käsittelykriiseliautoilijoilla maksatetaan dieselveroa eli käyttövoiman maksua mukaan sen takia että se diesel oli aikanaan halvempaa litraa hinnaltaan kuin bensiini. Nyt se on jopa kalliimpaa. Hallituskaan ei puutu asiaa ei kukaan välitä siitä. Nyt pitäisi kyllä joku bensa autojen maksaa niisuttua dieselveroa ja ennen kaikkea näitten sähköautojen ajelevat.
Se liki ilmaiseksi verrattuna dieselkäyttööseen alta. Moi, moi!
Tää on selvä johtopäätös siitä kun lehmät nautakaria lämmittää sitä ilmaa ravintonsa kautta. Ja nyt sitten on huomattu että ihmisillä on sama taipumus jos syö paljon hernäkeittoa.
sataan noista, jotta ei saisi noita hanhia ampuvaa eikä vähentää, mutta olisit viljelijät kun tekyvät työkset edelleen olisi kasvattu veljo ja karjo kasvattu ja Suomi jo tarvittuu kyllä minun mielestäni karjou matalustuotteita vielä tästäkin eteenpäin tai eikö niitä nyt yhtään tuota valopiliikkuvaa osa sillä evoskunnassa että vois antaa niin kuin luvan ampuvaa niitä. - Valkoposkihanhia. Valkoposkihanhia. Niin kuka eikö yksikään ... - Kyllä.
- Eiks meillä ole yhtään kansanedustajaa joka on puhunut? - No eipä taida olla kun siellähän niitä on no puistutta ainakin noita kaupunkilloisen noita hanhia niin kyllä minä kyllä minä nyt kauheasti hämmästelemään. On kun klavil päähän lyöty niitä hämmästään vaan ei kun vaan päivän jatko. - Minä toivotaan päivän jatko tiedään odottelemaan että kuka kansanedustaja rupeaa tästä sitten puhumaan. - Niin uskaltaako ruveta puhumaan? - Niin totta.
- Kyllähän sillä puhutaan mutta sanon kun että suoraan puhutaan mutta meillä ei ole aikaa vuoda siihen. - No niin. - Mä avaan jatkoa vuoda kiitoksia. - Kiitos hei. - Joo hei.
- Tämä tuli nimimerkillä elämän kiertokulkua muutaman hetken tallustellun. Seuraavien puheluiden jälkeen minä kerron meidän yhteystiedot. Voi tuohon äskeiseenkin kysymykseen vastata mikäli tuo oli kysymys eikä kommentti mutta sitä ennen nämä seuraavat puhelut. Eli hyvin erikokoista laastaria tarvitaan hyvin erilaisiin asioihin.
Timoista moittimista toisia kohtaan. Minä sanon että hallitus on ihan päin peruseista laittaa pian leikattaa vaan pieni tuloisilta jon lapsiperheiltä ja eläkeläisiltä oli karmeetta katsottavaa. Orpon kattos leipäjonua ovat kasvaneet kaikkialla jopa paikassa. Jatkakaa vaan saman malliin. Hyvää tuloja kiitos.
Jorma täältä eläkelänemme ja presidentti kun se on käynyt jo kohta kuuskyt kertaa maailmalla ja sitten tässä paikallisleissä luki että Relaanteri kävi neljä kertaa ja sitä saanut jo reissu lasseeksi ja sitten tuossa oli silloin kun ahtisaari tuli niin kansanedustajakin sanoi kun se oli aina siellä namiimpi missäs että passi pois siltä että en tiedä.
Kyllä tämä on jotenkin tuntunut että pahasti on mennyttä en tiedä onko kukaan samaa mieltä. Kiitos. Nämä nykyiset mopo kuskit luulevat että se on melu joka kuljettaa sitä mopoa. Minun aikaan ennen oli pappa tunturi että nämä niin se oli bensa ja ilma jotka pyörittiin ja kuljitti sitä mopoa. Eikö?
Olisi ihan järkevää että kokoomuspuolueen ja perussuomalaisten ja näiltä otettaisiin muutama tuhat euroa että saataisiin poliiseille alkometrien sijaan tai ei sijaan vaan lisäksi niin visipidimittarit. Hyvää yötä ja velvoitonta yötä. Eppä.
Arvonta on henkilöt jotka sen arvona suorittaa. Ne katsovat etukäteen tietokoneelta mitä numeroa on vähiten veikattu. Sitten ne valitsevat ne pallot. Onko näin vai onko jotakin muuta?.
Kansanradiotervehdys. Laskipulla ihan vimpelistä päivää. Vimpelistä päivää mitä kuuluu?. Soittelen ihan tästä nykyaikaista miten on tuomari pulaa nykyaikaista?.
näin oli sitten lain jalkapallo, pesäpallo, jääkekoripallo tai tai mikä tahansa niin tilanteessa ei osautunut oikeastaan minkäänlaista ratkaisua vaikka kuinka on yritetty. - Siis meillä on tällä hetkellä Suomessa monissa eri lajeissa tuomaripula. - Kyllä nimenomaan pesäpallossa on suojettu tuomareista ja sitten jääkeen kossakin tahtoo olla että tuota niin niin. - Mikä tähän tilanteeseen on johtanut? - No se on se mielikuva mikä nuorilla on että aikoinaan kun on opona -
pitkäaikaista joskus jutellut oppilaiden kanssa ja sitten vähän niin kuin markkinoinutkin tämmöisillä kesätyönä näin niin minulle sitten kahden kesken sanotaan että eivät halua mennä tuomaris koska he eivät tulekään sitä haukkumista ja että kun heiltä vaaditaan sitten heti ensimmäisessä pelissä niin kyllä paineet on niin valtavan kovaa. Esimerkiksi tuossa oli yksi jääkiekkotuomari kun oli viisito mutias poika niin ensimmäinen ottelu näin niin se jäi siihen koska hänet haukuttiin ihan täysin lyhtyyn. - Aikuiset ihmiset haukkui. - Kyllä kyllä.
Kyllä juuri näin ja niin eihän herran taihan jos se on ensimmäistä kertaa tuomari niin ei vaikka jääkiekkossa vaikka on pelannutkin jääkiekkoa näin niin ei semältä tee hänestä heti valmista tuomaria että vaikka luistelutaito onkin niin... - Se on kyllä semmoinen toistuva ihmettelyn aihe itselläkin kun saa lukea aina muutaman kerran vuodessa uutisen siitä kuinka vanhemmat on itkettänyt jotain alaikäistä tuomaria pikkulasten pelissä että mikä saa aikuisia tuomaria.
pillastumaan. - Se on tämä tulosvastuuna, että kun niille maksetaan korvausta, niin minun mielestäni se on niin eräs tuomarinimeä ja nimeltä valitseva tasolla, että kun pitää olla tavallaan sitä tasoa, koska pitkut tuomarit niille maksetaan korvausta. - Niin eivätkä ne vanhemmat sitten huomasse, että tuossa tosiaan on alaikäinen ja tämä on tosiaan pikkulasten peli. - Niin ja sitten kun yleensä on niin kuin nuoret tuomarit, niin ne on kauheat arkoja. Arkoja sillä lailla.
että he saattavat tuntea säöneiden, vaikka he ovat itsekin pelanneet jääkiekkoon, mutta sitten kun siellä saattaa olla entisiä pelaajia, niin sitten ne tuntevat sen lajin luonteen, niin kuin jääkiekkohan on, tämmöinen hyvin maskulliilinen peli, niin he ovat sitten hyvin arkoja viheltämään, ihan selkeätä jäähyjäkin näin. Ja sitten se, että valittamisen kulttuuri ei kuulu esimerkiksi jääkiekkoon ollenkaan, pitää osoittaa semmoista kovuutta, mutta sitten kun se romattaa, niin se romattaa kerolla.
Itse en osaa jo tosiaan sanoa, että mitä siihen pitäisi tehdä, mutta ehkä enemmän pitäisi olla tämmöistä tuomaritarkkailua ja sitten olla tällaisia harjoitusteleja, joten tässä aluksi näitä tuomareita ja olisi semmoinen ihan suunnitelmallinen, tavoitteellinen se eteneminen ja ettei heti liian kovia pelejä. Ja sais vähän kokeilla erilaisia rooleja, että...
- No mutta me jäädään sitten odottelemaan, että mitä kommentoi muut Kansanradion kuuntelijat? Mitä ehdotuksia tähän on ja mitä mielipiteitä herättää? - Päivä jatkuu. - Moi.
- Kirjeen tai kortin, jos haluat lähettää Kansanradion, niin oikea osoite on Kansanradio pl 7 9 000 24 Yleisradio.
Sähköpostia jos haluaa lähettää, niin sitten osoitteeseen kansan.radio.yle.fi. WhatsAppin välityksellä teksti ja ääniviestit 044 5515464 ja sitten se meidän vastaaja se on 0800 15464. Siellä se automaattinen vastaaja odottaa ympäri vuorokauden sinun puhelua, tosin sinun.
Nuntaina automaattiselle vastaajalle annetaan tauko, silloin paikalle saapuu ihmisvastaaja. Eli lähetyksen jälkeen sunnuntaisin kolmen tunnin ajan täällä ollaan. Tähän loppuun vielä ilmoitusta ja kehotusta. Minä puolestani meinasin kehottaa, että laittakahan ihmiset ne kaikki kodin ikkunat auki, että pääsee saapuvan kesän tuoksu täyttämään kodin, mutta sehän nyt on itsestäänselvyys. Totta kai kaikki ovat jo niin tehneet, eli ei siitä tarvitse erikseen muistuttaa.
Lassu Olkinora kiittää kun olit seurassa. Mä toivotan oikein hyvää päivän jatkoa ja voi hyvin.
Sitä ollaan kun kusisukassa hiljaa, yleensä tästä sanon, että kansakin on ystä tyhjimmättä. Se ei uskalla ottaa kantaa, mutta mistäs täällä ottaako? Ei ole mitään reittiä ennen kuin kaikki pimenettiin ja ylisettänyt tätä nykyinen menua, että se on ainoa oikea ratkaisu kuin kuvannetta Suomen hallitusta ja EU:ta ja Amerikka ja näitä kaikki, että nämä on nöyrästi kuunnetettava ja sieltähän se meni jatkuvan ja elämä meni päin perse. Mutta näinhän sekään kun ei ole vapautta puhua kansalla mitään. Kiitos, hei!
Voi demokratiaa ei näe tätä päivää. No turha pitää mitään vaaleja kun kansa on pöljää ja narrattavaa, eikä se mikään muut jos iso anti tulee ja tuputtaja sinne häsläämää. Sama meininki jatkuu ja koiraomistajien puolue on suurin ja kaunein. Ei ne lapatossut saa edes koiraveroa. Rensinmaiden rappio voisi pysähtyä jos USA:han tulisi olivaistikin tuoni. Heippa!
Haluan kertoa siitä, että kukaan meistä ihmisistä täällä meidän planeetallamme ei tiedä, mikä on oikein ja väärin.
Kukaan ei ymmärrä, mitä tämä koko maailmankaikkeus oikeastaan on. Ihmisillä on semmoinen suruuden hulluus, että kun ne puhuvat, että maapallolla tapahtuu jotain, niin ne sanovat, että maailmassa tapahtuu jotain. Eihän se niin ole.
Ei voi olla paljon älykkäämpää elämää kuin täällä meidän planeetallamme. Ihmisten pitäisi pikkuhiljaa jo ymmärtää se, että aika kulkee ja se vierii. Miljoonia vuosia on aika kulkenut ja se menee omaa kulkuaan riippumatta siitä, mitä me ihmiset ajattelemme ja mitä me teemme. Meidän pitäisi pikkuhiljaa luntea jonkinnäköistä nöyryyttä siitä, miten pieniä me olemme tässä maailmankaikkeudessa.
Kiitoksia.
Heipä hei, semmoista asiaa vain soittelemaan, että nytpä hän on ihan parhaimmillaan. Nämä villiyltit ja villivihannekset tuolla luonnossa, että ihanat nokkoset ja kaikki kasvaa siellä, niin sieltä kandee kyllä lähteä keräämään ihan talvin varastoon näitä nokkosia ja ehkä vähän vuohenputkea ja tämmöisiä muitakin, mitkä on helposti tunnistettavia niin horsmat myös, nuoret horsmat on oikein hyviä.
Kannattaa kerätä, kannattaa säilyä niitä myös talven varalle, koska eihän sitä tiedä, mimmonen talvi tästä tulee. Miksipä ei olisi pikkuisen etukäteen jo oma varainen siinäkin asiassa, että hän keräilee oman talteen. Ei tässä muuta. Iloista kevättä kaikille.